well it is my distinct pleasure to
introduce our guest today john kelsey is
associate dean for humanities in the
college of arts and sciences at florida
state university as well as
distinguished research professor in the
FSU department of religion his research
and teaching focus on questions of
political ethics particularly in
connection with Muslim and Christian
thought professor Kelsey's recent
publications include arguing the just
war in Islam published with harvard
university press in 2007 he has received
fellowships from the john simon
guggenheim foundation princeton
university center for human values and
trinity college dublin institute for
international integration studies please
join me in welcoming professor kellton
well thanks for that introduction and
I'm especially I noted that when you
said my book was published with Harvard
that you didn't make a face about that
as i understand it what they all as i
understand it this microphone is for the
the taping and not to amplify my boys so
can everyone hear me all right if at
some point you can't just give me a sign
now a professor wolf told me I should
take about 20 minutes and I told him as
you can no doubt ascertain I'm from the
American South so 20 minutes to a
southern a 20 minute limit doesn't
matter very much it's not that we have
more to say it just takes us longer but
I'll do my best I want to talk about
three things first I want to talk a
little bit about September the 11 2001
and reminiscences I suppose you would
say and then second i want to ask where
we are in our conversation scholarly and
popular about the significance of or how
we ought to think about the movement
al-qaeda and related movements within
the sphere of islam and then finally i
want to talk about what that means for
the study of religion particularly
related to faith and the ambivalence of
faith and globalization so first 911
hard not to reminisce a little bit since
we are after all on the seventh
anniversary of the attacks on the world
trade center and in washington DC
probably a lot of the news coverage this
morning where the tapes of the planes
flying into the towers replayed and news
footage was shown in New York and
elsewhere brings back memories and
causes people to think about where they
were and what their original reactions
were the news footage shown this morning
reminded us I think of the initial shock
at the footage shown really around the
country and eventually around the world
of the planes flying into the towers
first people thought there was some sort
of terrible mistake when the first one
went in and then a few minutes later
when the second one went in people began
to talk about a deliberate attack and
wondering what had happened who had
carried it out from shock to outrage
lots of talk about whether more was to
come people lived it seemed almost in a
kind of quasi apocalyptic atmosphere in
which things were breaking and you
didn't know exactly what was yet to be
revealed that last part for me that
quasi apocalyptic feeling are more
generally the feeling of strangeness
about all this was I'm sure amplified in
part because I was not at home when
these attacks occurred I was not in
Tallahassee I was in Cleveland on a
visiting appointment that fall where I
was to give I had contracted the spring
before to give six public lectures on
the topic Islam and the political future
a topic that took on new meanings after
these events okay thank you adjustments
are necessary sometimes yes but the
strangeness was multiplied as in the
coming months in Cleveland first almost
the next day a plane landed at the
cleveland airport and the entire airport
was quarantined because the plane had
left its scheduled flight pattern and
landed in an emergency condition and no
doubt the airport authorities thought
that it might be carrying a bomb a
little bit later a prominent imam at the
islamic center outside of cleveland a
person who had been for some years
intimately involved in ecumene
dialogue in the city was exposed by
local newspapers for statements he had
made some years prior to that that were
I think it's fair to say vehemently
anti-american and anti-semitic he was he
protested that he had changed his
opinions and that his ecumenical work
actually represented what he wanted to
contribute to the faith community but he
was ultimately forced to resign from his
post during the time of controversy over
this Imam who incidentally had an
adjunct teaching post at the University
where I was giving my lectures during
the time he was being exposed and his
legacy being debated another strange
thing happened a native clevelander
evidently in a fight with his girlfriend
over whether or not he was brave enough
to actually do something about the
terrorist who had flown the planes into
the Trade Towers and into the Pentagon
he got himself well in my part of the
world we would say he got himself all
liquored up and he took his car about
two in the morning and drove it down the
long driveway leading to the Islamic
Center and crashed into the main part of
the building I suppose he thought that
was a brave act fortunately he did not
hurt anybody there wasn't there at that
time anybody at that time of day he
didn't hurt anybody except himself he
dislocated broke both his shoulders and
broke a leg if I remember correctly the
upshot was there was a communal outcry
about this attempt to do damage to the
islamic center in the islamic community
and the members of the center were quite
gracious i have to say they refused to
press charges with respect to this
gentleman and only expressed their
regret for these kinds of
misunderstandings misunderstandings made
even more strange by the fact that not
long after that
a Sikh temple in Cleveland was
firebombed evidently the perpetrators
thought that they were attacking Muslims
strange things feeling of strangeness
about that time and the strangeness was
amplified I think for many people by
their first glimpses on videotapes of
Osama bin Laden and Ayman al-zawahiri
these two fellows bin Laden of course
speaking with that famously Placid
manner that he has Zawahiri more
excitable enthusiastic from one point of
view yelling and screaming from another
but then giving their messages to us in
a background of wilderness somewhere in
Pakistan or Afghanistan almost as though
they came from another time and place
strangeness now we moved quickly at
least many people did from that feeling
of strangeness and other feelings of
outrage and shock to the question who
are these people and that's where the
second part of these remarks I want to
take off what have we learned in the
seven years about bin Laden Zawahiri and
those either with them are motivated by
them are motivated by a view of the
world like there's I think it's fair to
say that in popular discourse and even
more in scholarly discourse we have
emerging two paradigms two ways to talk
about these folks the first we might
call the terrorism paradigm or some
people even like to call it terror ology
the kind of paradigm that's expressed if
you were to go over the library and pick
up a journal like terrorism and
political violence a very interesting
journal that deals with terrorism and a
variety of settings
through time this is a discourse that
focuses on tactics these are people
these were people on 911 and as
expressed in subsequent statements by
bin Laden Zawahiri and others these are
people who are engaged in a form of
indiscriminate fighting where the
ordinary rules governing the conduct of
war rules that are built in to the
Islamic discourse or tradition of
thinking about justice and war even as
they're built in to the just war
tradition familiar to Europeans and
North Americans those rules require that
a fighter conduct him or herself with
honor in particular by distinguishing
between combatants and non-combatants
argit's the terrorism paradigm fixes on
the ways that al-qaeda and other groups
violate those codes of honor and wants
to understand what they're trying to do
with respect to that the other paradigm
that is emergent deals more with
al-qaeda as a religio-political movement
and wants to see the tactics as
occurring within the framework of more
overarching religio and political goals
now myself I hold as it will be clear to
the second of these paradigms I think
that what we have learned in the seven
years since 911 is that we are dealing
with a Muslim religio-political movement
which utilizes a particularly violent
form of irregular warfare in pursuit of
its goals and which is I think we have
to say deeply though controversial II
related to islamic tradition are deeply
in terms of the course but ambivalently
related to islamic tradition and the
thing that I try to do most
comprehensively in my book with Harvard
University Press is to display the
contemporary argument among Muslims that
is occasioned by the tactics and claims
of al-qaeda now let me take a moment
just to illustrate what it is that gives
an appeal to both of these paradigms
that terror ology or terrorism paradigm
and the religio-political movement
paradigm on the other first on the
Terrorism paradigm in both cases i'm
going to use quotes from Zawahiri august
the fourth 2005 osawa re-issued a
pronouncement about the 77 bombings in
London and he warned both the people of
the United Kingdom and of the United
States and others as he said o peoples
of the Crusader coalition we have
offered you at least the opportunity to
stop your aggression against the Muslims
we have offered you the Lion of Islam
the strugglers sheikh osama bin laden
may God protect him offered you a truce
so that you will leave the lands of
Islam did sheikh osama bin laden not
tell you that you could not dream of
security before we live it as a reality
in Palestine and before all the infidel
armies leave the land of Mohammed but
you have made rivers of blood in our
countries so we blew up volcanoes of
rage in your countries our message to
you is clear and unequivocal you will
not be saved unless you withdraw from
our land stop stealing our oil and our
resources and cease your support of the
corrupt Arab rulers as the statement
went on Zawahiri warned of how many
thousands of deaths would occur
threatened more acts of violence and so
on the point here is that this is the
familiar voice
of the terrorists we get a celebration
of indiscriminate attacks threats of
more to come demands for specific kinds
of action the entire discourse with one
exception lends itself to the analysis
of those who would say this is political
theater in which religion is simply a
kind of ad on the issues the rhetoric
are in the form of those familiar from
the study of international terrorist
groups like the ones analysed in
terrorism and political violence the
only feature that even gives this a
shade of an Islamic character is the
reference to the lands of Muhammad from
which the infidel armies are supposed to
withdraw now of course if you want to
evaluate the terror or terrorism that
little mention of the lands of Muhammad
is a pretty important add-on it can
immediately be seen to resonate with
some of the great themes of Islamic
tradition will refined Muhammad fighting
in the medinian period of his ministry
roughly from 622 to his death in 632 to
create a zone of security for the
practice of Islam in the Arabian
Peninsula if one accepts the tradition
by which the prophet sent letters to the
rulers of surrounding empires before his
death inviting them to accept Islam or
to come under the protection of Islam or
to face the challenge of war then
Muhammad planned to expand this zone of
security and so the Muslims did in
European and North American scholarship
we read of the early Islamic conquests
but the mention of the lands of Muhammad
actually in pious memory thinks of
brings up the image not of Muslim
conquests but at Muslim armies
liberating the peoples of the Middle
East North Africa and eventually a much
wider territory from tyrannical
governments the early expansion of Islam
in other words in pious memory is not a
matter of conquest it's a matter of
liberation and with it regime change
whereby tyrannical forms of government
are replaced by Islamic governments
governments in which the rule of God's
law is supreme it's interesting here
that in the pious tradition about this
program of liberation and regime change
once Islamic government was in place it
wasn't that everybody had to be a Muslim
and in one since conversion was not the
direct point government was no
conversion might follow the old proverb
that the religion of the people follows
the religion of the ruler a Muslim text
cite that but the point in the first
place was to establish sound government
and again in the imagination of the
pious the kind of imagination at which
this reference to the lands of Muhammad
is aimed in the imagination of the pious
the change of regime was not an
imposition of something foreign but a
gift for Islam the condition by which
people submit to God's guidance is the
natural religion the natural condition
of humanity even so government by God's
law is natural from this point of view
it provides the best chance human beings
have to live in peace and justice
now as I say that little add-on the
reference to the lands of Muhammad it
can evoke all these things that I'm
talking about is that what Zawahiri met
when he inserted that will consider this
address of his from 2004 true reform is
based on three principles the first
principle is the rule of Sharia because
Sharia which was given by God protects
the believers interests freedom honor
and pride and protects what is sacred to
them the Islamic nation will not accept
any other law after it is suffered from
the anti-islamic trends forcefully
imposed on it the second principle of
reform is the freedom of the lands of
Islam no reform is conceivable while our
countries are occupied by the Crusader
forces the third principle of reform is
the Muslim nations freedom to run its
own affairs this freedom will only be
realized in two ways first freedom of
the independent religious judicial
system the implementation of its rulings
and the guaranteeing of its honor
Authority and strength second the
freedom and the right of the Islamic
nation to implement the principle of
promoting virtue and preventing vice now
as that quote indicates Zawahiri is not
interested in promoting violence for the
sake of violence that undoes about well
several hundred recent scholarly
interpretations of what is going on with
these movements that operate in what I
would call the terror paradigm it's not
violence for the sake of violence
there's a positive vision here whether
we like it or not is another question
but there is a positive vision and the
fighting he holds is the only means to
accomplish the goal he goes on in the
text that I was just reading from
to warn those Muslims who think that the
proper reform can be put in place simply
by words and diplomacy says no it's
going to take fighting to accomplish it
Zawahiri I think meant precisely when he
spoke about the lands of Mohammed to
evoke the pious memories that I have
spoken up so wha he wants to stand along
with bin Laden and others for government
by divine law and as he does so he also
stands against something democracy for
example Zawahiri and other al Qaeda
spokespersons clearly understand
democracy as government of By and For
the People in fact in the famous
document in the shadow of the spears by
sulaiman abu ghaith who was for a time
after the 2001 attacks a kind of almost
a kind of press secretary for al-qaeda
you read that article and you almost
think that he has read and is quoting
from the Gettysburg Address when he
talks about what he is opposed to so re
and others standing for government by
the Sharia and they understand that to
entail standing against democracy which
Zawahiri and others hold is bad for
human beings it's important here I don't
think we want to say that this is a case
of someone who misunderstands democracy
and while someone like Zawahiri is
perfectly capable in the text i was
reading from in other statements of
tweaking the Western powers for
inconsistencies and hypocrisy that's not
really his point either he thinks
democracy is bad for Humanity it's
certainly bad for Muslims but ultimately
it's bad for humanity and one of the
reasons it's really important then for
Muslims to establish a state that is
ruled by divine law is so that they can
carry out their mission
of commanding right and forbidding wrong
of calling people to live in accord with
their true nature he's not far from
evoking the famous saying attributed to
the Prophet that every child is born in
Muslim it's the child's parents who make
of him or her a Jew a Christian a
Zoroastrian or something else if you
take Zawahiri seriously he wants to give
every child a context in which he or she
can hear the message of Islam and
reclaim his or her natural identity now
where we go from that is we're not
looking just at a terrorist movement it
is a religio-political movement which is
engaged in a particularly violent form
of irregular fighting it wants to link
up with more local or regional
resistance movements around the world
and to move them toward its goal of a
state large enough to be a player in
global politics in terms of this course
it wants to shape or even control
globalization if globalization implies
the advance of democracy of capitalism a
free trade of the regime of human rights
then governments inspired by this vision
that al Zawahiri puts forward would
resist and would say they have their own
vision of globalization an Islamic one
now what this means for the study of
religion and for the ambivalence of
faith mocks viber taught us two things
about religion at least two things first
whatever other purposes religions play
they serve to give believers a vision of
legitimate social and political order
whatever other purpose they play they
give believers a vision of legitimate
and political order
and inspire them to take action in
accord with that vision of legitimate
order as you can tell it's my view that
al-qaeda has tapped into something
pretty deep in pious imagination in
terms of a vision of what kind of order
is good for human beings makes for their
welfare in this world and points them
toward their welfare in the next but
then the second thing faber said has to
do with change or ambivalence he writes
neither religions nor human beings are
open books they have been historical
rather than logical or even
psychological constructions without
contradiction often they have borne
within themselves a series of motives
each of which if separately and
consistently followed through would have
stood in the way of the others are run
against them head-on in religious
matters consistency has been the
exception and not the rule babers point
is that over time we see things shift so
that a vision of legitimate political
and social order that seems basically to
enshrine and confirm the status quo
somehow gets turned on its head and
supports revolutions in religious
matters consistency is the exception and
not the rule and I think it's fair to
say that contemporary Islam is in a time
of crisis when al-qaeda and other groups
are fighting for the power to define the
pious imagination for years to come this
is where ambivalence the ambivalence of
faith comes in in arguing the Just War
in Islam I talk in broad terms about
three groupings in contemporary Islam
and of course one needs to refine always
these kinds of typology zor groupings
the one the militant point of view
that's the al-qaida point of view
advocates of divine law governance in
the strict sense who join that goal with
a particularly violent form of irregular
warfare in which distinctions between
combatants and non-combatants are not
held to be are not held to be binding
then we have the great broad Center I
think of contemporary Islamic political
thought which you might call more
traditional advocates of Islamic
governance in which an Islamic religious
establishment is very important and in
some sense governance by divine law is
right but who have a little bit looser
view of how you derive divine law from
existing precedents and sources then the
militants do and who are repelled by the
militant tactics if you look at Islamic
websites if you read Islamic texts the
advocates of Devon of more traditional
advocates of Islamic governance are
clear that they do not believe that the
tactics of the militants are warranted
by are consistent with Islamic tradition
and this particularly a matter of the
targeting issue for them there are some
things that the Muslim conscience just
cannot approve even if in some sense the
militants are on to something about a
problem in contemporary life then the
last group I described as Muslim
Democrats people who read Islamic
sources and who argue that it's not just
the tactics of the militants that's
wrong but the whole notion of an Islamic
religious establishment is problematic
and needs to be put to the side they
attack in other words not only the means
of the militants but the goal and they
want to say that the regime of Human
Rights is the Islamic form of government
so that if the militants tap into pious
imagination by saying talking about the
Mohammed with unbelief and persecution
and fighting at Medina the Muslim
Democrats want to talk about Mohammed at
Mecca from 6-10 26 22 in which he said
he was called to preach and in which he
said persistently to those of his
followers who said please authorize us
to fight against persecution he said I
haven't received an order to fight I've
only received the order to preach if the
militants want to tap into pious
imaginations by talking about the Muslim
expansion as a program of liberation and
regime change the Democrats want to say
well you know it wasn't all that simple
and straightforward the motivations
weren't always Noble and in some way the
the pious construction is ex post facto
the conquest take place first and then
we develop a way of saying we've got all
this power now how should we think of it
well you think of it in pious terms and
the Muslim Democrats want to say no it's
not all that clear and by the way they
want to say it's not also not clear that
an Islamic state meant just one thing
there's a great variety of precedence
here finally the Muslim Democrats want
to almost make a charter a political
charter out of one particular verse in
the Quran and the the wiry and others
dispute with them about the meaning of
this verse Quran to 256 says there is no
compulsion in religion and for the
Muslim Democrats this becomes a verse
that legitimates religious liberty and
that then in turn becomes the first
fundamental right of human beings which
leads to a way of orchestrating
political order whereby legitimate
political order is in accord with
international standards of human rights
now we could go on and perhaps we will
in the conversation to say more about
variations of these groups and the
crisis and contemporary Islam crisis in
the sense of
element of challenge and opportunity but
perhaps right now I've said enough to
suggest the connection of 911 and the
ambivalence of faith so I'll stop